you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum boom good start to a
year Ryan I agree you know it's been a
little stressful but I'm taking things
in stride more this year I think you
know I was having anxiety a little bit
like this morning in bed thinking of all
these things and I said stop I just
couldn't deal with it right then so it's
like if you can't control you can't just
get [ __ ] off shelve it man shelve it and
I tend to do that and it's like that was
the old me and I like now you're not
gonna freak out you know how you're
gonna go for a walk you know get up
drink some water gonna meditate you're
gonna go for a walk and I feel better
it's just logic it's science it's just
like get your body going get your brain
turned off a little get distracted do
you think you get distracted a lot in
what way I mean you you know you have a
lot on your plate like you know if I
look at things in perspective Ryan you
know you're a guy who's very talented
he's very funny and keep going well I
will but like you know things happen at
different times for people yeah you know
what I mean like I could picture you as
a huge successful story you know have
your own show doing whatever you keep
going until something just clicks it's
like the universe right yeah so you work
your ass off and you're like I'm sure
you sit there sometimes you're like
going alright what am i when is this
gonna you know one of these folks can be
more appreciative what am i when is this
gonna turn into some gold when is this
gonna so you keep all these plates
spinning no for sure yeah so is that how
do you deal with that how do you deal
with like stress and going okay because
you know you're not a millionaire or you
know you're like you know you well
wouldn't that be fun if I was a secret
millionaire and you want a life the
millionaire engineer no yeah no I got a
lot of plates spinning right now this is
one of many things that I'm doing and
yeah it kind of feels like a lot of
times it just sort of feels like I don't
know if you ever had a drill like this
did you ever play football yep
like when you know those drills were
like you just supposed to run through a
bunch of guys they're sort of hitting
you with like the little little bags
yeah it is sort of feels like it's just
a constant stream with that and like
every every now and again you get like a
little you know you hit a little a clear
patch but then like someone comes out of
nowhere just like hits you it's like a
gentle little nudge but it's a knock you
off your feet and go like [ __ ] when is
this gonna stop it's like you're just
working hard working hard and you're
like okay what was this necessary
yeah is this necessary to keep getting
hit like this I was on a roll not to get
hit today goddamn we all get hit but
it's like you know I
for me it's like oh you know I love you
know I love my friends and everything
but like I have a lot of talented
friends and you're one of them I'm like
you know I know this is just like hey I
wish this would be just blow up and be a
huge success and you know we could do
bigger and bigger things and I could pay
you more and I could do these things but
it's like you know you do a lot of
things until one thing really hits but
you hope it's something that you're
really passionate about ya can only hope
but and well then yeah you just keep
going yeah I mean I'm getting used to
the hustle it's it's uh it's been a
weird last half a year but I'm starting
to get used to the you know just like
sort of like balancing everything do you
ever just say Calgon take me away who's
that
say you're too young no those are all
commercials like Calgon take me away
just poppin skinemax movable bath and
stuff anyway I know it's gonna happen
for you and I know look it doesn't
matter in a sense you're happy you're
doing your things you're loving them
you're good at them you're doing a lot
of fun interesting things and I just and
I am that you're probably a lot happier
than I am
so this is fun name I like this well I
love that you're doing and I just like
it open I hope it doesn't leave me
abandonment issues but you know so far
you know we had the top 13 I hope you
enjoyed that we had never done something
like that I got a lot of people even my
buddy answered man who's a celeb you
know start track and we did a movie
together he's like oh dude I love the
top 13 that was fun and I think unless
he's being sarcastic cuz he wasn't on
the top their team but I love answering
he's very interesting we have a lot of
great guests I know I say this every
year or the last year's really like the
first weekend you be doing this here and
happily I think this next guest is our
95th guest I believe I could be wrong no
one's been keeping track except you know
some really loyal fans that I read their
messages but that's a lot of people and
we've you know I'm sure some guests
you're like I don't really want to hear
from them but I encourage you to one
because it helps the show too because I
think you learned something no matter
who I interview and three learned
something about them and sometimes
guests surprise you and you're like well
I didn't know anything about them and I
found them interesting I read that a lot
I read that in the comments I read that
the letters are be there for my friends
and even guests like I'm like [ __ ] I
don't know who these people I didn't
know I just had a guest done that we
just interviewed now which I won't talk
about but I was like
it was like whoa there was crying and
there was like emotion and just I think
everybody will relate to it I'm like
even if somebody doesn't like this band
it doesn't matter so I encourage you to
again get people to subscribe and write
reviews for inside of you with Michael
Rosenbaum and it doesn't go unnoticed I
want to thank my patrons if you haven't
joined patreon and if you want to you
can I still thank you for anything
you've done but the patrons have gone
above and beyond and you know they
subscribe to the show and they get extra
material and Q&A is with me and they get
to ask guest questions and it's just
really cool when it's almost like a
little relationship thing that we have
and it's something special I always said
if I get enough patrons I'm gonna do a
big karaoke party so I did say that
also hey guys knocking point whines
Steven emails company Tom Willy and I
did another series of bottles of wine
that we did tastings and this year I'm
the pure he's the evils pure evil
go - knocking point wines calm you could
use my code pure and take an additional
$10 off knocking point wines calm slash
taste makers - Club
it's called anyway do that if you if you
dig the wine what else I got Portland on
January 23rd and 24th Tom Welling and I
will be in Portland if you guys are near
there and and we're going to do a small
of the nights improv show and be signing
and stuff and that's fun we're also
going to Mexico in March which is really
cool and I think I'm going Australia in
June and a lot of cons coming up but I'm
excited really about Mexico and Portland
the Mexico you know I've been but I
didn't realize we had this many fans in
Mexico but like some days are sold out
I'm like wow man this is cool so I had
to do this little inter this little
video Ryan and I was like you know
saying hello to the Mexican well I don't
speak a lot of Spanish but I said hola
bienvenidos me I'm always Michael
Rosenbaum but I go me llamo ASA Lex
Luthor
and I did a little video like that so
that was fun um what and it's just me
llamo ya you don't see me on Louis
that's one thing I do know so I thought
it was my name is me amo s knew just a
Miami Michael ma'am let me get your last
name
tears tears but as it is literally the
only thing I know about Spanish really I
wish I knew more I should yeah we know
we didn't speak it in the house
really my dad doesn't speak Spanish your
mom my mom's English well then why would
you sort we you know I mean you mean
English from another I like like great
British English yeah great show today
I've known her for a long time she was a
lead in the movie back in the day that I
directed we have fun talking about that
briefly homeland come on she's been
nominated for a lot of things she is in
Deadpool won Deadpool to Gotham v she's
stunning inside and out she has a heart
of gold it was really fun hanging out
with her and she just she brightens my
day she's just a beautiful person and
she's got a great story and she talks
about things like divorce and she talks
about things like hey you know how do
you deal with that and how do you yeah
there's a certain maturity that goes
into dealing with you know exes and life
and doing things for the children which
a lot of people don't always do when
those children suffer and I know she's
got a good head on her shoulders and
she's got a pretty neat perspective I
loved having her didn't you Ryan yeah
she was great what did you love mostly
about her how she said squirrel yeah the
the Portuguese it was fun remember the
the the word it was like ski lows like
the rapper right you know yes kilo and
she said it and she how did you say that
as you'll hear all of this it's pretty
amazing
again I encourage you guys to go to
inside of you pod on Twitter and
Instagram and all that and follow us and
retweet it and and subscribe and all
that stuff and thank you for the support
and the love at the very end of the
interview of course I'm going to do the
outro say a few things make a few
special shout outs and have a little
chat with you so you could stick around
if you want and much love let's get
inside of Morena Baccarin
it's
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you got off a plane you're one of those
people that you get you know this though
tell me more let me know sucks to hear
that you think by the way you think your
name marina would have meant something
like Beauty natural beauty but it
doesn't means Burnett just brunette
that's gonna boring right yeah but I
want to name or something like brunette
Lorena do you know how I got my name my
mom Brazilian yeah she was a famous
actress when I was born in Brazil how
famous like as famous as you are now no
no no does she resent you for it just
get right into it anyway no she does so
she was famous like famous light but
like famous right known like she was on
a soap box yeah and so in a little a ton
of theater and it's a smaller community
and you know whatever and there was a
newspaper article from the hospital when
I was born right and she kept thinking
and looking at me she didn't know what
to name me and that the title said baby
Marina doesn't have a name yet because
my Anna means brunette little some Bates
that they meant like a little tawny baby
doesn't have a name yet and then my mom
was like oh that's a good name yeah
really I know and it's great that I
moved to the United States because
that's much more exotic than being in
Brazil and being called brunette right
hey there's brunette yeah brunette and
then everybody goes okay that's your
nickname what's your real name and I'm
like now this is my [ __ ] name so in
Brazil do they kind of do they think
it's funny that your name is Bert do you
think it's they think it's my nickname
and they're like no that's actually
that's actually my name good for your
mom yeah and then you left how old the
first time I left when I was 7 and we my
dad got transferred he worked for this
really big company called Globo which
was one of the biggest network so it
used to be in Brazil he got transferred
using news editor and so we all moved
because Brazil was in the [ __ ] can I
curse a lot
oh yeah Brazil was in the [ __ ] it was
you know just I think
Silla dictatorship at the time really
awful economy and we moved but my dad
thought that my mom always wanted the
kind of suburban amazing American
lifestyle and goddess like a
three-bedroom apartment in Forest Hills
and my mom got there and was like oh I
thought we were moving to New York how
far as Forest Hills outside of it's
right yeah it's not New York City
Manhattan it's 30 minutes at least at
least I'll be 45 right on the train
still probably expensive I don't know at
the time this was you know the 80s but
he was doing well who's me okay he was
very catchy and mom was making money
being an actress she was and then she
quit to move to New York and she was
like I don't I don't do Queens so she
stayed for a year and she's like this is
miserable I'm in the suburbs with two
kids you get to go in the city and work
all day I don't speak the language my
kids don't speak the language
everybody's crying every day to go to
school you just became English none zero
zero
I remember being made fun of because I
saw a squirrel for the first I mean you
have to imagine that's super old from
Brazil you know being used to being on
the beaches in Rio and moving the forest
between those Queens and I'm wearing
like long johns and it's cold you know
and we're out in the yard and a squirrel
goes I go Shakeel ooh cuz that's what
you you know the squirrel isn't give me
an example let me hear how you think you
sounded when you were seven my akira-kun
young boogie what did you say
mama want a hamburger say it again my
Ocala Callie oh yeah oh my god that's so
adorable yeah thank you
now it's amazing I guess I did you stick
you tryin it knows it's a beautiful
language I'm put him on the spot
Portuguese is a beautiful language are
you glad I didn't say Spanish yes thank
you very don't people hate that and you
know what the capital don't say it cuz
you know watch this Ryan what's the
capital of Brazil its Brasilia yeah
brother yeah it's not Rio de Janeiro its
Brasilia
is it safe for me to go to Brazil
depends where you go a lot my listeners
a lot of them at least on my Instagram
it shows you like this thing that
someone showed me and it says my
audience leave Mexico Brazil San Paulo
yeah so I'm just wondering can I go
there yeah you just have to be careful
you have to be street smart you know
just like any big city but the problem
with San Paulo and Rio specifically are
there's a just a huge discrepancy
between well you know there's it's
either you're either poor or you're rich
and there's a lot of people who can't
survive and who are barely scraping by
and so it creates violence creates you
know kidnappings and for ransom and that
kind of stuff and muggings on the street
and you have to be really careful it's
really unfortunate cuz it's the most
beautiful place in the world I got you I
get you about Brazil I want to go there
I love Chapel I think um I think you'll
have a grateful people yeah you know do
you ever look in Americans and just suck
out come on it's so much prettier in
Brazil yeah you do that a lot of the
time so it means there's a lot of
natural beauty it's the skin it's the
olive skin ya know I think also honestly
there's a joy for life there that I
haven't seen anywhere else when you say
joy for life what do you notice
differently like if you could say if you
can express or to talk about one moment
that you see in Brazil and compare it to
a moment in the States like just a that
shows that napping I'd you seen those
like typical videos of little boys
playing soccer on the street baby yeah
you know you grow up with that kind of
like passion for something the beaches
the way everything looks the way people
like they leave work early in Rio they
go sit on the beach they have you know a
beer or whatever and they go back to
work like where else do you do that
enjoying the moment and being where you
are even though your circumstances
aren't great you just find joy in the
things that you have I think where
designs are really good at that we were
talking about being present yeah we had
a little dinner before this because
we're friends we've been friends for a
while yeah and we keep in touch and I
know you're busy but you know what you
have it you've gotten to be a bigger
star now than when we first met and you
haven't like you're still the same arena
I hope so well yeah I know but you you
just you're
easy to talk to it's gonna sound weird
but like I don't want to be a star like
it's not about some I think some people
are in it because they want to be famous
of course I want to do good work and
have a good life and I worry a little
bit about what happens when you start to
be famous I mean I want to have a simple
life in a way like I want to I want my
kids to grow up and know what the
reality of the world is versus in the
other day my husband Ben is doing a play
in New York right now he's doing a play
on Broadway what's he doing he's doing a
play called grand horizons nice that was
a movie with I was it event horizon it's
nothing to do with that that's not the
sci-fi movie no no satisfy if I Broadway
play dosoo
it's really good it's a family drama go
play it starts James Cromwell and Jane
Alexander amazing actors anyway we go I
take the two kids on his dinner break to
go visit him and we're walking to see
their dad on Broadway like to have on a
dinner break
like that's not normal most kids don't
live like that right and I want my kids
to understand that that is not normal
that's a privilege but they're exposed
to so much just so much to art to
theatre to whatever being in New York
but that's and that's a privilege that's
important that is important and it's got
to be tough to sort of like implement
certain things to balance them they're
too young to know right now I mean
you're waiting six so like six-year-old
is understanding that a little bit so I
think I just need to like remember just
every once awhile slap them around and
remind them yeah that's not real yeah
back to about being present we were
talking about that yeah and I always
feel like you are someone that has
always been present now I'm not one that
has always been present it's hard to me
at hard for me sometimes to to focus and
I feel like when I'm really into
something I can focus on it if I really
just zone I'm in the zone yeah because
I'm interested whether it's a
documentary or
a movie or but don't you find that more
and more maybe it's because we're actors
like I don't the movies don't do that
for me anymore like I can't lose myself
in a movie
ranae's a wiggler I didn't know that
well her that way I said well I I talked
about this a while ago but I watched
judy so you're saying when you watch a
movie you can't connect as much I just
see the shot and like I'm looking at it
in like a right way and like I
appreciate it it's been a long time
since I've lost myself in a movie man
that's wow that's interesting because I
feel like that's that's the one way then
oh maybe it's the only way I mean when I
connect when it happens I find myself
sometimes lost if a movie is good enough
or it's speedy I feel like it's speaking
to me or I can relate to like I can't
relate to Judy there's moments in Judy
Garland where I just go maybe it's
mental illness I don't know but at the
end of Judy I lost my [ __ ]
I was alone on New Year's Eve just
happened and my friends want me to go
downtown and I wasn't mad I wasn't angry
I wasn't like ah I just don't feel like
it I was like hey guys I've seen you
almost every day I had people over for
Christmas morning I had enough Sanath I
had an ornament party I've had screen or
nights I love you but I don't need to
see you again right now and that for
some reason of this universe or my your
body sort of telling you yeah you need
to just chill out yeah why I watched
Judy I don't know because there's many
movies that I want to see you know a lot
of other screeners yeah academy movies
and I remember my I kept seeing a
trailer every once in a while for Judy
yeah well I've heard of me I don't know
if you'll connect to it like I did but
at the end I mean she was 47 when she
died
yeah I was I'm 47 and she died right
before her 48th birthday and I'm so much
older than me
yep how old are you 40 yeah thank you
but I
I just remember you know she had pill
addiction horrible since she shouldn't
but she went through so much that I
couldn't even understand when she was
young and you know those things that
come on at the end of a movie like Judy
went on to do this six days later she
died it just I could feel like that it
just moved me yeah and I when I say cry
I wasn't just going oh my god that's
that I was 15 minutes hard couldn't stop
crying and I never do that I never
non-stop cry usually it's a cry for a
minute or two and I can go let go 20
seconds you know lost my Grandpop's
crying but this one lasted like a
lifetime and I was weird I didn't want
it to end I think it was really
cathartic it was cathartic and my dogs
came up to me and I just was like my
eyes were the next day they were burning
yeah they hurt and so I connected with
that there's certain things in movies
that didn't you didn't I text you that
night and say hey I'm coming tomorrow
this was this this was two days ago yeah
yeah then you go I'm yeah great I'm
going to bed like you were really short
which you know aren't usually yeah just
I just cry
I was I was done yeah and I just felt
like sometimes it's important to just
reflect and to you emote yeah I mean
you're Brazilian so you probably cry a
lot you know no but I do and I I it's
your car
but as I get older it gets harder like I
I find myself holding it in a lot I'm
embarrassed to cry I'm embarrassed to be
vulnerable why why are you embarrassed
to cry because I feel like I cry all the
time because I feel like I cried too
much because I walk to my car
well you know like I have this thing
called a period and like you know at
least once a month my career I okay I
you know I had a rough day yesterday I
mean I cried a lot yesterday and I
didn't know why we talked about why
could have now New Year's Eve yeah no I
drank too much on New Year's Eve that's
definitely Partizan but I was also
PMSing it was deeper than I felt like so
much and I think it's okay to allow
yourself to have those moments but I
judge myself and through it I was like
my husband kept asking me like are you
okay I'm worried about you I'm like you
know what I'm fine I just need to cry I
don't know why I'm gonna try not to
dissect this like I'm just gonna cry and
it was okay and I feel better
does he ever think is it me am i doing
so sure you know even what a guy's not
like yeah yeah a woman like imagine of
guys like you are you so quiet bye
something's wrong I'm fine no but I
wasn't doing it like that wrong I was
looking at you I was letting him it was
I I was like I don't know I just think I
need to be in this place right now but
what's something you said earlier about
connecting with something like that in
the movie like judy and allowing
yourself to cry and having that
cathartic moment and being present I
have a hard time being present and I
think watching a movie I'm not being
present I'm like looking at the
technical aspects around it and really
yeah I think so but lately I've started
um pottery because we're also talking
about art before and that I I will I
will be at the wheel making something
for three hours and the time will go
like that and I won't realize it and it
is so soothing and it's so nice to be
doing something that takes your
attention like that that you're not
self-conscious about that you don't care
how great you are how great you are how
you look how you look doing it how you
what you're making like I'm not in it to
make beautiful pottery I'm in it to just
create something and learn a new skill
or to just disappear in your mind
yeah present not the meditation it's
yeah so great I think that's awesome
see that's great that's that's like
applying certain things those are good
that we call them good habits right yeah
because we're talking about like I had a
lot of bad happen so you still have a
lot of bad habits but I cut out a lot of
them that's all right
that's a glass and that's the microphone
yeah that's still good that's still the
microphone I go like way around it that
was a drunk moment even though you're
not talking you promised yourself you're
not drinking
and now after New Year's for three
months three months yeah yeah when you
drink do you feel like you're like I'm
gonna get drunk tonight I'm gonna get
really drunk yeah sometimes I can tell
sometimes it syncs up on me I don't do
it off and I have two kids I'm up in six
and I hate that feeling of like
I feel disgusting and then I'm crabby
and I'm not enjoying my day like so I
just don't do it a lot I have my glass
of wine
pretty much every night but that's a
glass I mean that's different
I think that's alcoholism when you have
to have a glass of wine every night no I
don't I think that's being a mom you do
you when you have children you tell me
about it because it's like what I
imagine people do when they have a
cigarette or like you know you just kind
of need to exhale sometimes and having a
glass of wine and I also really like the
taste of wine I enjoy that right took my
hands a lot that's fine that's a good
actor I think people talk because that's
what people do they talk with their
hands anyway getting back to drinking my
drinking problem yeah
I don't drink like that that New Year's
Eve was maybe the most I've had to drink
ever and one at one like I had a great
time you did I had a great time it was
just three couples you sloppy
you know we danced I never noticed you
being sloppy I've seen you drunk when we
did back in the day okay I remember you
were drunk a couple of nights because
there was like people are out drinking
because there was nothing to do I don't
know I didn't really enjoy it but the
few nights I did when everybody's drunk
I never knew you could see there's
something like maybe they should stop
yeah but I never could tell it god she's
hammered but I know my limit really
that's the thing I really do I don't
know there's like two drinks for me is
plenty Ryan do you know your limits uh
yeah no I went a little harder on years
even I wanted to as well
yeah are you obnoxious no I'm a fun
drunk are you you say that I'm sure a
lot of people say they're fun drunks and
if you ask their friends are like what
an [ __ ] I mean I've had I've had
[ __ ] moments too that happens really
yeah you can't prevent that I get I just
get happy I think like I'm more
affectionate and I'm happier and I'm
because we sir yeah it does offend what
you do my my friend Dineen does these
things where I love her but she does do
this thing that annoys me annoys me but
I know she actually does love me she'll
look at me literally like this Mike I'm
like I know it's coming and she does
this to Ethan to she go
she'll tilt her head a little with a
smile I love you right
oh my god all right no no
I don't see it like oh I love you too
maybe she only does that when she's
drunk well she does it 99 percent me I
don't smoke I love you thank you it's
great night but it will be one of those
moments for a fun comfortable right on
that uncomfortable just like here comes
Maine's had a few too many Mike why why
can't you just no I think it's sweet I
think it's sweet
I do you find it hard I mean for a woman
I think it's easier to say I love you to
everybody like a woman can say a hard
time well I'm saying like a son like him
Ben is his or his parents alive yeah can
he say I love you to his dad yeah see
that's that's a nice thing I don't think
I've ever said it well see that's that's
a great thing that's so important to say
I love you to a little boy yeah a little
curl yeah it's huge you don't understand
I'm telling you first-hand experience if
you look at your son with conviction
it's not like you're throwing it Adam
constantly yeah but if you're like hey I
want you to know I love you yeah I
really love you I'm proud of you and I
really want you to be happy and I'm with
you I mean that will that's more than
any gift you could ever buy them yeah
that is the gift it's true
and so if Ben's doing that but I think
even if you can't say that and that's
how you are towards them your attitude I
think that's that's okay too I mean yeah
hearing I love you is very important I
think showing you actions like it's also
important talking to your son playing
with him being interested in his life
interested I think is huge Ben seems
like he has a really good disposition
yeah he does he's just a nice guy like
I'd hang out with Ben and I don't know
if Ben would hang out with me he says to
say hello so I think okay well that's
nice yeah hi Ben he is he's just a nice
guy I'm like he is I mean you know he's
a human being he's got his moments as
well and his moments you know he's like
all of us does he get angry yeah he's
been a hater
yeah no it's not like that he his anger
is quiet it's contained he has to walk
away he doesn't want to do anything he
regrets it's very admirable actually and
it scares me a little look when he gets
like that I'm like oh I [ __ ] up you
know what I mean right
he doesn't want to do anything he
regrets he doesn't want to say anything
he regrets good on him like it's hard to
do that takes years of self like I would
assume it takes a long time to yeah
because a lot of times you're hearing
something that sounds so foreign you is
so wrong yeah that you're like [ __ ] off
I have no and then that just feels it if
you're fighting with a Brazilian yeah
now she's got it he might be like no no
no push ooh go what is it the squirrel
shoo go shooter what's the thing for a
sq of the school it's cute it's cute say
it again say it again ski you know the
whole sentence I know she lose that's a
great thing I want to see here that
movie
[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by CB
DMD a trusted leader in the CBD industry
you know I just need CBD this is just no
getting around it I have CBD all over
the house it's it's a part of me and now
that you know a lot I think a lot of
people are afraid Ryan because they're
like oh but what about the THC there's
no THC in this all of the products from
CBD MD premium CBD derived from
ethically sourced USA grown hemp but THC
free completely THC free you never have
to worry about getting high this makes
it for me
it just alleviates my pain it really
does I feel like I agonize the pain my
whole life since I'm 18 all the
surgeries and when I apply this stuff on
I just feel better
each product is backed by a 30 day money
guarantee there you have a exceptional
customer service that can answer your
questions you have at any time before
during or after a purchase to help you
make an informed decision you know I
went to the Laker game last night and my
head was turning a lot left to right
watching the players could back down and
you know up and down the court so you
must been close I was relatively close
but my point is I had neck surgery like
seven months ago so at the end of the
night my neck was effed so what I do
lathered myself with some CBD MD they
have so many different things to they
have the tincture
they have the you know the topicals they
have gummies so you can get what you
want
CBD MD is dedicated providing you with
the natural support you need to feel
your best and to make discovering the
full potential of CBD even more
accessible CBD MD is offering all the
listeners 25% off when you use the code
IOU at checkout yeah
CBD MD is offering 25% off to our
listeners of inside of you 25% off it's
incredible when you use the code I owe
you a check out once again that's promo
code I owe you at CBD MD dot-com 25% off
your next order of premium CBD oil
products from CBD MD inside of you is
brought to you by squarespace Ryan you
like these guys do you can build your
own website yeah it's amazing even I can
do this even you it's that easy they
should say even Rosenbaum can do it
folks if you want your website to stand
out stand out with a beautiful website
you can do it all by yourself all right
here's the things that you could do
right you could turn your cool idea into
a new website and what does that do now
your idea seen by other people and it's
exciting showcase your work
blog published content sell products
services of all kinds promote your
physical or online business announce an
upcoming event or special project and
more do you see how this could help
inside of you yeah how could it not of
course I love this I think it's really
cute really cool taquille it's very cool
beautiful templates created by
world-class designers you get this from
Squarespace Squarespace does this for
you bite they give you these things
customize the look feel settings
products and more with just a few clicks
everything optimized from mobile right
out-of-the-box a new way to buy domains
and choose from over 200 extensions
analytics that help you grow in real
time
built in search engine optimization free
and secure hosting it goes on and on
nothing to patch your upgrade ever 24/7
award-winning customer service it makes
sense so you're ready to start a new
business Ryan all the time make
standout get started with Squarespace
think it dream it make it with
Squarespace head to squarespace.com for
a free trial and when you are ready to
launch use the offer code
iou to save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain at
squarespace.com enter code I owe you I
owe you you know what that stands for
inside of you
but I want to get into your career a
little bit too but like that's not what
course what the show is about the show
is about like hey you're being inside of
me right yep thank you but the show I've
had actress Coco we haven't even talked
about this project we haven't talked
about the office Rainn Wilson said
Maggie I go oh you want to is like no I
love this and you've done a lot
serenity Firefly a homeland got
nominated for an Emmy in 2013 yeah yeah
you're welcome
and then Gotham and then Deadpool won
Deadpool - you got a movie Greenland
coming out with Gerard Butler you've got
I mean like you're successful you have a
lot of money mmm I live in New York City
I'm putting two kids to private school
there's not enough money in the world
we'll get into that but like you um
you went through tough [ __ ] yeah as we
know like people get divorced my parents
my mom's been married three times my
sister's been married four times my dad
just got divorced for a second time I
know what divorce is yeah and maybe
that's why I'm single
maybe that's why I haven't gotten
married because I see how much
dysfunction there is I'll get married
it's wonderful it is but the first time
around I'm sure there was wonderful
moments but it didn't work out no I
didn't what why why do you think it
doesn't work out you know there are so
many reasons for me you know I I and I
and by the way if I hesitate here it's
because I'm hyper aware that my son will
be old enough one day to hear everything
that I say about my relationship and I
want to be respectful of that we were
just talking about this before Yeah
right I didn't know myself well enough
when I got married I didn't admit to
myself that the things that that I
actually wanted the things that I wanted
and that I still want I wasn't
ballsy enough to to let it be okay that
I that I wanted certain things and that
certain things were important to me I I
grew up you know Brazil has this sort of
like misogynistic kind of like you know
male dominance in relationships and and
culturally and I you know I left Brazil
when I was seven for the first time and
then ten four
and I didn't have that as an example in
my household my parents were you know my
mom will ballbuster so my dad was the
more like sedate one but I didn't also I
also didn't have a they got divorced
when I was 20 I didn't have an example
of a one-er a great relationship my mom
raised me to go you know never cook for
any man you're gonna be successful
you're not gonna have kids until you
were in your 30s or 40s you're always
going to take care of yourself first
because this is what she wanted for
herself and she filled me with all of
this and I was like this is what I want
I am NOT gonna cook for anyway I'm gonna
be a feminist I'm gonna vote and it
wasn't really what I wanted I didn't
want to I didn't isn't I mean it's so
[ __ ] hard right and it's like me to
movement whatever but like I don't want
to be equal the same as my man I think
that there is a man and there is a woman
and I think that's okay doesn't mean I
should get paid less or it doesn't mean
that I should but we don't do the same
things and we don't serve the same
function in a household and I think
those roles can change and they can be
what they are for the right relationship
you know with who whatever you want for
yourself but I didn't really know myself
well enough to know that I am much more
traditional I realized then I I wanted
to be cooler than I am I love that Ben
opens doors for me I love that when we
started dating he you know made a big
deal about like no put your wallet away
like a man should pay and I love that he
and I'm this has nothing to do with my
ex this is to do with my current right
this is things right away that he was
doing were more of what you were
gravitated to yes and I and it made me
feel good and it made me feel loved and
wanted
and also he heard me and listened and
emotionally emotionally connected with
each other in a way that I hadn't before
and you know these were all things that
were extremely important to me that I
didn't realize how much does he still do
them yeah all the time does he ever not
hold the door with you he always does I
mean I get ahead of him which I
sometimes do whatever but like how do
you feel about the old Bronx
moment where instead of going around the
door and opening the door I go in the
driver's side door and then Lee knows
that when I open I open the door that
way that's fine
not as good but that's fine that still
works right yeah thank God it works you
know it's hard though you know you have
a kid with someone you're married and
then you up and you move to New York is
it tough to because you know my parents
[ __ ] loathed each other after the
divorce in fact I made a rule and I
still hold that rule now I say you are
not allowed to talk about anybody else
except us when we're having a
conversation if you start talking about
that or I'm hanging up it's not fair and
I know within a while and it was hurtful
and so do you sort of have a rule do you
know we do know hey I will not talk
about your dad
absolutely dad whatever and that
absolutely he is a good dad and I I do
not my son is a smart boy he I'm sure
picks up on tensions that we have with
each other my ex and I but that is a big
rule for both of us you just you cannot
bring a child into it and sometimes it
happens accidentally or sometimes
there's a frustration or something that
you're dealing with and the kid
experiences it but we both I believe try
I know I really really really try to not
let that be a thing right yeah it's
really and sometimes resentment is hard
to let go
you know what's harder yes resentment is
hard to let go you know ego ego and you
know you broke up because you don't get
along right like there's something that
just doesn't gel so that's tough but you
know I can't let that get in the way of
my you know of their relationship and my
relationship with my son and it's a
completely you know you can't you have
to be the bigger person it's just not
fair to him the harder thing though I
think we're adults and we will deal with
hold and deal with the harder are the
questions that he's gonna start to you
know we split up when he was 1 as he
gets older he starts to ask questions
and lately he's been saying I you know I
want why can't we all live together and
I think that's it makes me laugh in like
the best possible way like that's so
sweet
he wants us all to be married to each
other and to all live in the same house
and I feel like it's really important to
give him
fantasy you know and to just acknowledge
sake I mean who knows he wants us
together he wants his family together
and that's a sweet thing and you want to
encourage that I think in a kid and then
you turn your head your husband battle I
think there's a sitcom in there
somewhere house there is right it's
called not in a million years
well thanks for being open about that
and that's it's interesting because you
know you you rarely see two people that
can be like we can actually have a
conversation and talk about our kid and
it's fine and there's no Rosetta and
there's no and I don't know if you even
are near there maybe it's just right now
you have the time with your son I have
the time with my son
and that's what it is yeah I mean it's
you know it's more like that but we do I
mean you have a child together you gotta
discuss doctors and you discuss schools
and you're just unity there are things
that you need is it hard though do you
ever feel like you're not agreeing on
certain things just all the time but but
just to not agree oh you know I mean
like he'll say something and then you'll
go well I'd rather instead of going you
know what you could have this one I mean
maybe in the beginning but I think like
as it goes on you really have to think
about it's always a time why why do this
why are we doing that but I find I mean
with Ben Ben and I argue about things
all the time where I'm like well I like
you know to eat it this place could
whatever like I want to give them this
blue carrot and he's like that carrot
has no nutritional value you know we're
like argue about like stupid right right
there's no um your parents like then my
mom yeah she my dad is not really in the
picture oh yeah he's a divorce
Brazil you ever see him you know I tried
for many years to reconcile and keep a
relationship and they you know it got
really really really complicated and I
thought it was best to have boundaries
at the moment I have I'm hopeful that at
some point soon we will be connect but
right now it's easier to I mean just I
guess not span we don't we speak
occasionally let me email but it's not
what it should be
right I mean does that really make you
sad does it make you sad that you don't
have a relationship with your dad that
you want to have does it do you ever
think about it yes but it
where our relationship was was more
damaging and more sad than not do you
know I mean I mean well his relationship
so he wasn't giving you what a father
should yeah you weren't getting out of
him with a violated as a daughter yes
and that was more hurtful and you gave
him every opportunity to step up but he
just didn't step up yes that goes back
to you saying a man should be a man and
step up in a way you know like tough as
he just to table no he's not at all
tough I mean he's very nice he's very um
I have been preventive I'd you know in
the relationship like I become the
parent and I don't need that
relationship and I need the other way
around yeah I feel like I feel like I
have become the parent like in many
years ago so moving to another country I
learned English quicker than my parents
did of course because they're in their
forties and it takes a while and
whatever my brother and I were fluent
within two or three years and so we
became or I because I'm the oldest
became the go-to like hey can you
translate for that from what are they
saying
well let's I need to open a bank account
you need to come with me I need help
parent-teacher conferences what is your
teachers saying I'm like translating and
you know and it suddenly like I don't
have the support I'm supporting and then
it and then it bleeds into other areas
emotionally and all kinds of things and
from a very early age
I'm giving money buying yeah yeah it's
amazing how you know you do it you do
you know what I always say it's oh it's
so weird when no one want when someone
doesn't ask for money when you're making
it like my grandmother
for instance my grandmother she hates
she won't let me buy her things I bought
her since my grandpa passed I bought her
flowers every week she gets thank you
yeah thank you
welcome I know you mean it so I
appreciate it
you know I buy her flowers what roses
every week and you say Mikey stop why
are you doing this it's so expensive
you're buying me filing because I love
you and I want you to smile at least
once a week cuz I know you're having a
hard time she goes you're just special
you especially know I know I'm special
the teachers told me that
but I I you know I want to buy her
things like I had to go out and get her
a TV set a new TV yeah and I go dad
let's go buy or a TV yeah I'm gonna go
buy a TV
you better not buy me anything I don't
need anything but those are the people
you wanna buy my friend Tom he doesn't
want you buying him anything
he doesn't want you to lending it but
it's when someone's hands always out
it's really hard on us but it because it
plays on guilt and it plays manipulation
and you know I've supported my parents
since I could work when I was like 20 21
you know which is like not an age you
should be supporting your parents and
it's hard it's really really hard and
there's also I think there's also a
cultural aspect to that too by the way I
mean in Brazil you live with your
parents until you get married and then
when you get married you move out and
then you kind of start supporting your
parents you know and I think that that's
something that was just kind of
ingrained and in them but I don't live
in Brazil I agree but you moved me here
I love you but do you ever think
sometimes I learned this in therapy but
you want you're always waiting for that
moment in life where the person you love
will become the person you always needed
or wanted that make sense almost like
you know like I love my mother uh-huh
I stopped imagining or thinking you know
one day she's just gonna be that right
responsible narrative just sincere and
she has her moments now she's I think
she's trying my dad's trying but but
that's called you know my old therapist
said what's crazier than you know some
of the things you experienced as a child
and your parent what's crazier is you
thinking they're gonna change that you
think after all these years you're still
gonna find a way to make them be what
you always this is who they are yeah
this is the person you're looking at so
you have to ask yourself do I want a
relationship with this person and if I
do what kind of relationship and you
have to be in control of that
relationship in the sense that how often
do I want to speak to this person how
much effort do I want to put into this
how much do I want to how much
time do I want to spend with them and
that really is a that had taught me a
while but when you stop trying to parent
and you stop trying to fix I know what
the fixing well then if you just stop it
and you just say this is what I will
this is what I want in my life because
at the end of the day it's your life is
your life at least alone just alone it's
my life it's my life what are you saying
there Mickey remember that that's a
really good impression like that where
that came from I got on that because I
think there's like I said I always try
to fix things but like I'm like you know
what the more you try to fix people the
more broken you get ya know I feel like
I've gotten more broken I'm like as the
years have gone on because it's
debilitating and stressful and draining
and futile and futile and it's just
crazy it's like it's fantasy for me to
think that I'm gonna change someone or
get someone on a routine I have to get
on the routine I have to just be as
healthy as I can be because otherwise
what am i doing yeah well who am i
living my life for what you know having
kids really put some in perspective big
time if you break down like nothing gets
done nobody gets taken care of you know
and you really that's one of my new
year's resolutions this year honestly is
to take better care of myself and to
allow myself more alright time for
myself I will I will like run on empty
I'll just keep going keep going till I
completely collapse how are you gonna
change that so in the New Year's
resolution I'm gonna be less I'm gonna
feel try to feel less guilty and we'll
try to work through that guilt of like
you know what I can go to a coffee shop
take a breather read a book for 30
minutes and reset so I can have more
energy for my kids later just like not
have that you know what can I be doing
more for them like spending more time
with them playing with them more doing I
do that a lot and I and it's work it's
about quality in our quantity if that
makes sense yeah I remember days it
confused
there was a line where the guy goes it's
not about quality man it's about quality
exactly it remember that Ryan about that
specific line you know I can only
remember the Matthew McConaughey bit
like about these freshman girls ma'am I
get older I stay the same alright
alright alright that was a good one so
look all your success I mean I don't
know how you do it because I can barely
like I can imagine you've got movies you
got TV shows you're flying out to LA and
you're telling me how much it's how hard
is cuz you miss your kids like you miss
your kids but you're you're working to
give them a better life to give yourself
a better life to have enough money so
you can retire and later on in life and
but most importantly I love it you know
I really try not to say to them you love
your job I have to go to LA because I
have to work I want to do you love
everything you do is there a job you're
like besides my movie is I mean oh
you've had a lot of fun I think it was
one of your best times in your life I
mean are you more picky you you're
obviously more now you're getting before
it's like all right I'll do V ya right
I'll do like I said when you have kids
it puts a lot in perspective and I weigh
the time I'm gonna spend away from them
with the job so is it worth it
you know is it something I need to do
and how can i balance and have a balance
I really you know that's the hardest
part I think as a working mom is
balancing wanting to work because then I
feel good about myself and I have more
to give to them right I'm not just
financially but emotionally with the
time that I that I won't be with them
but it's important I think to show them
that I can have my own life and my needs
and my wants and it's okay to like take
care of myself do you give yourself a
certain amount of time like let's say
you're learning lines first of all how
do you prepare who helps you if anybody
to record your lines your voice for the
other lines that you and then how many
hours a day do you give yourself to work
on them see you then you can give the
rest of the time to the family it's
really different for every part you know
if I'm doing like some guest starring on
a show and it's super easy and I it's
the kind of role that I can do in my
sleep I don't prepare so you don't just
you don't put a lot of effort into I
don't give them what they want and you
move but not that I put zero effort I
just tell myself like get rest look good
feel good feel good about yourself like
I do the things to prepare in that way
but you know your lines but my lines are
not because it doesn't matter
I'll get them and it's
be fine that's not the hard part I think
honestly with children it's the the the
the hygiene of like getting enough rest
and allowing yourself to leave the house
with plenty of time to like not have a
crazy morning or you know maybe like not
being the one who takes them to school
that morning or whatever like doing that
how do you get rest is it routine do you
go to bed at a certain hour and wake up
at a certain hour do you have to do that
there's a lot I have sleep problems so
if I don't go to bed by 11 or 12 if it's
later
everything's effed up right let miss
your sight you're so right like I got I
gotta go to bed right now that's one of
the hardest things about having children
is is that that gets completely [ __ ]
but how do you do you here's my biggest
question for you the most important
thing you're gonna say in the show how
do your eyes not look swollen how do you
not have like bags under your eyes
good genes falkman I must have those
Hungarian Romanian genes because like
that's all I could think of I don't even
care about being a good actor all I
can't care about God please make my eyes
less swollen in the morning but that's
your look like that's who you are who
cares no hate like looking like [ __ ]
us I am exhausted 95% of my life are you
are you exhausted on set can you fall
asleep on set not on I have an intense
amount of energy I'm tired a lot but I'm
like I'm buzzed I'm on like I'm not but
I'm working I'm working
I rarely can take naps during the day I
don't like and that's one of the things
that I'm gonna work on this year is
allowing myself to switch off whether
it's meditation for 5 to 10 minutes or
laying down and taking a quick catnap I
need to be able to do that more but I
will be up with kids all night and then
get up and have a full day and then like
just do it again but that comes with
knowing that you have to like if I did
that try to do that 10 years ago there's
no [ __ ] way I could do it right it's
because you know you have these little
people that need you there's little
people how cute is that they're little
people 6 a.m. they're patting into my
room like good morning it's time to get
up
Stephen hey Lou skyla I wish I was a
little bit skewed oh I find this so
fascinating like I mean your career dude
when you were doing Deadpool 1 I
remember when we had one
at a Chinese no sushi place in Vancouver
and we had a conversation about Deadpool
and you're working with Ryan Reynolds
and everything III didn't know what
Deadpool was I don't either I know I
remember I was sitting there I go what
do you think I don't know seems he's
great everything's great
that's well you want you want munagi
sure what's gonna knock e you had no
idea yeah so were you absolutely blown
away when you saw the movie yeah I was
did you think this is gonna put me in
another level no I mean I still didn't
know how people were gonna receive it
when I was shooting I was like oh oh
this is this is fun
like I'm having the best time I hope it
turns out great you know and then when I
saw it I was so blown away
and then when it came out and it was the
hit that it was I I still sometimes
can't believe it
the first movie you didn't get paid much
I got paid okay what's okay I can't tell
you why let me just ask you this how
long did you work two months on the
first one yeah ooh on and off for two
months yeah 200,000 or 50,000 I don't
tell you 300 I'll tell you later when
the mic sell 40,000 dollars but
ex-husband if he knows how much I met
you know the difference the difference
between one and two exorbitant
difference no I mean a bit a bump for
sure residuals at least tell me this it
residuals did you get more than $300,000
of residuals oh god I don't know ah geez
if I would have known well I got a
box-office bonus I got two ooh those are
nice that means when the movie makes X
amount you get a bump yeah it makes
eczema eat a bump you know many movies
I've been in never I never got that
bounce really all of them I know that's
really hard that's what that rarely had
much I paid for guardians is it weird to
talk about money I don't care I like it
it's just kind of fun because I think
people want to know some people go a
Cuba Libre talks about like but other
people are like going I want to know I
want to tell you what I got paid for
guardians get ready I only worked a week
a week come back a week and I was
unrecognizable as they put CGI all over
my face it was my body and my mouth to
make the three lines that I said 15
grand
amazing and I thought residually I was
like oh my god
this is me this makes up this made uh a
billion dollars I bet you I'm gonna get
so much did you get oh I did but ya know
I mean uh right so like people think
that you get a little and but they also
ended they do endl this is what people
don't understand the residuals go yeah
yeah look I get checks from the OSI for
one cent oh yeah I've gotten one cent
checks but you know is the thing it's
like people assume that you know you
make a lot of money when you do
guardians if you're a bigger actor in
the show if you're sure sure but like
after the taxes and everything I
probably made five thousand the studio's
really really smart they're really smart
the way they do their business model
because there's cameos right and the way
they define what you're doing you get
paid accordingly so even if it's
Scarlett Johansson if she's a cameo in
one of the Marvel movies like she may
not get paid her right I mean they do it
in a very smart way they do and I also
think nowadays they're like you want to
be part of the Marvel Universe yeah you
want to be part of the DC Universe right
get on your knees we'll pay you what we
want to pay in fact you're lucky to be
in this movie that's that they have the
power they do they do have the power
until you say no right well that is real
power and there's a straight and you
know what I is let me tell you something
it's you could say no you don't Lee what
I want and but you know what I bet you
really meant now how you have to be if
you're [ __ ] around trying to get more
money I know you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
it all only works if you mean it and
this is in real life if you are away my
friend wanted to quit UPS he's like you
know what oh no you want to quit a
subsidiary if that's the right word of
sits ups like something that's not UPS
but it's like pu s ok HUS why did I
spell pus it's all right that's he's
like [ __ ] this man they're paying me
like half as much as UPS who pay me and
I'm [ __ ] leaving I'm like let me tell
you something if you really want to go
and you're not trying to bust their
balls to give me your money you like no
[ __ ] that I'm not getting paid this
money I'm leaving I want to leave I'm
leaving out if you really mean it then
do it and he's like huh and then over
that came out he then he just couldn't
he couldn't he couldn't do it yeah so
I'm like I remember there's been those
moments and look a lot of times
if you have a family if you're working
you know you're making ends meet
yeah to say no is harder but if you
really mean it if you really feel like
you know they're not paying me what I'm
worth and for unprincipled I never had
this conversation recently where yeah I
was made trying to make a deal and well
we won't we'll leave it out the studio
and all that stuff like and you know it
was not worth it to me and I didn't end
it that was one of the times I had to
cancel I know I didn't come out to LA I
didn't you know pitch the show I was
gonna pitch don't payment and it was
fine with me it was genuinely fine with
me I was like I'm not and it wasn't even
this particular deal point was not even
about money right it was about the power
to make decisions and to to be a part of
the development process and I felt like
if I'm bringing a show to somebody I'd
like to have that power yeah yeah Jess
Whedon
yeah Joss Joss Jesus I've never worked
with him that's why I [ __ ] his name
he's brilliant yes he is I saw this
movie cabin in the yes yes I'm [ __ ]
loved and I want to work with this guy
yeah do you ever think why is he not
casting me now I did serenity I did
Firefly I do wonder about that sometimes
yes what did I do when I was at home
with dad he he works with people over
and over again
uh-huh but I'm one of the only actors
that he's never worked with in it which
is it were you [ __ ]
no we had a great time together Joss is
a wonderful woman
she's such a good-hearted you know this
maybe I think I'll cast you there was
one thing that he did call me for it was
a long time ago a TV show that he did
but it was like a scheduling issue if I
couldn't do it but that was it I mean
this was like 20 years ago do you regret
anything in terms of like turning down a
job there's there's a job that I've
turned down that I've regretted it's
really hard to say no to work when when
you don't work a lot and when you don't
know when the next job is gonna come
right and that still is hard for me you
know I had to turn down something at the
end of last year that was with a friend
and that was that is one of the hardest
things to do and I actually did like the
script
I know that he'd been trying to make
this movie for a long time and but it
just the timing it was like not right
for my family mmm there you go
and in my heart I was like I feel like
I'm gonna go and do this to do it and
not because I want to do it and I but I
I did kind of like I could have seen
myself doing it I just didn't want to
put that much effort into it I don't
know like there was something about the
time away from my kids that it was gonna
be too hectic and insane and I was gonna
be going back and forth and they were
going to come and visit me and it was
like and I was like you know what I'm
just not gonna do this is gonna be and I
had to turn a friend down and that was
really really hard really hard you
didn't turn me down when we did back in
the day I didn't that was fun
we we made this little it was under a
million it says on IMDB it was a million
but it was under a million I think you
could tell that when you're on sat it
was just like we had a girls trailer and
a boy you know one trailer for it was
for women by women I think we had 12 11
actors in the middle of nowhere with a
crew that didn't know what they were
doing for the most part except someone
we brought famila and they did like
Bradley and those guys but I had to fire
the sound guys right away yeah but you
did that and you were already successful
you're successful actress and I couldn't
believe you actually did it I remember
we met in green black yeah yeah and you
I go by the scripts and I was like this
is hilarious oh this is fun
yeah and I go well you want to do it and
you go are you offering me this and I go
[ __ ] yeah oh my god this really
beautiful talented actress wants to do
and let me tell you something I'm not
saying this I swear to God at all that
is holy I really on GEB Whedon nobody I
mean the cast is great I'm just saying
nobody was a bigger delight than you oh
thank you you were my rock and I know
that you guys went out and I couldn't
and I'm so exhausted cuz I was the lead
and I was doing everything and I you
know but you were so kind where you
could have easily been like what the
[ __ ] he's a first-time director doesn't
know what he's doing there are days when
I didn't know what the [ __ ] I was doing
there was a couple or I was like I'm
lost need help man good days where I was
like I'm good
but you were just eight I can't say this
enough I don't know if I ever told you
but oh you you didn't tell me but listen
a class act like I think you kept me
together
knowing that my leading lady a woman
that I didn't have to get the kiss we
didn't kiss on didn't I remember no we
were about to in the movie okay I just
remember going she's a little lady she's
in you know a lot of scenes and she's
just so cool about everything waiting
around getting a you got a fire the
sound guys day one but you were just
dynamite to work with so Joss but go
ahead what and this is how I know that I
love doing what I do right I get a
situation like that and it doesn't scare
me if I was in a situation like that and
you had been an [ __ ] different story
different story but I knew that you were
trying trying your best
you were great at it you know there were
some questionable moments for the
thorough but it felt good because we
were creating something and it you know
it we were all in it together and I'm
like all for that yeah you were you're
really good all in all the time mm-hmm
have you guys haven't seen that movie
it's go back in the day it's very sweet
movie it was it was a really sweet
little funny and you just wanted to
laugh you go I just laugh I do
everything seriously the time additional
laughs and we did it was a raunchy
little lowbrow fun I laughed a lot we
biotic outtakes you see on the end of
the movie if you don't even want to
fast-forward through the movie look at
the outtakes yeah of marina losing
remember there was some [ __ ] where I go
god we got a breather over here this guy
I'm at laughs oh my god you laughed so
hard so loud and it was just it was fun
to be around it gave me the strength I
think to continue it really did so I
thank you for that and I'll consider you
thank you I hope you'll consider working
with me someday if I give you a script
in your it's the time and your family
isn't compromised and it's a good script
I find that if I turn it down yeah but I
wouldn't be offended no I know that but
I know that about you yeah I wouldn't
alright it would give me a little bit of
[ __ ] I don't think I would I'd be like
hey here's the deal you should do it
because whatever and I'd give you the
spiel and I'd say hey this is it and
you'd have your notes and you're gonna
go hey I love you but I'd only do it I
got done we're done we're good friends
it's not gonna be weird now totally I
know and I know that about
yeah I get it yeah so all these roles
you've done you're married happily it
seems like Ben's a great guy I mean what
do you you say you love work right you
say I love to work is that something
that McFaul receive like I want to act
because I know you do other things but
like a lot of actors like myself and I
think this is what I get in trouble with
it's like oh you know what I want to
write I want to direct I want to produce
only and I spread myself too thin and I
start to veer away but I also told you
that I know everybody it's weird when
people are saying hey you're good at
something and you should do that and you
make good money doing that but then
you're like I don't really love that so
I talk about purpose I talk about gifts
like you're you're given a gift yeah but
what is that gift and you want to go to
work the goal is anybody out listening
you want to go to work with joy you want
to go hey how can I make a difference
today how could I have fun today an
element of fun and [ __ ] something that
you really I think that is the biggest
gift when you can go do something you
really enjoy and love and so and I'm
still searching for that and I think
this is part of it this podcast but do
you truly just love it I truly love it I
truly love it it comes with its
challenges for sure I would really like
to direct one day I think I would be
good at it I do too I think that I would
really like to produce and I have
developed and produce a little but
nothing that's really gotten made past
the developmental stage I know I
remember talking a couple times about
projects yeah that's everything me I
know how many projects have had that I
know I mean that ending and then gone
this if people knew the story behind how
things got made it's incredible you
spend so many years hundreds of hours
years and nothing gets made and you get
paid zero I know so that's do you enjoy
that I do like that very much and I like
the control that comes with that I'm
very a type and I'm very in and I like
being charged and I like that and it's
really interesting you know being a
woman in this industry I'm not gonna say
just being an actor because I would
never do you know just it's not a bad
thing but it's there's more power and
having you know be able to produce and
having more say so you want to mix it up
a little bit I do
ever get bored have you been on a TV
show like for instance Gotham do you
ever just go [ __ ] bored bored of this
role do 22 episodes of a show we did a
hundred episodes of Gotham who could not
get bored doing 100 episodes of
something it could be the greatest show
on television you know people were
listening or huge government how would
she get bored with Gotham well it's not
Gotham you're getting bored with it's
doing like got one scene for ten hours
where you're like I've said this line a
hundred times
yeah bored I'm gonna go home it's 2:00
a.m. it's New York City I'm freezing my
ass off outside on the street yeah and
that's I think that's with anything I
don't have the patience anymore for like
the idea of a nine-to-five job or nine
to four ten to five is you know I guess
because I'm older now and I'm just like
but the thought of the show is by the
way it feels like a nine-to-five in a
way you know yeah I mean I don't know
man I've had luck I don't say bad luck I
just have been on shows where I'm
they're 12 to 14 sometimes 50 now you
know I don't mean that I meant to say
like a 95 I mean it feels like a
predictable it feels boring right and
I'm saying that maybe just a regular
nine-to-five I mean obviously again it
comes down to you make more money if you
can land a show yeah if you can you can
it's very difficult and people don't
realize it's like oh I remember the
first show I did I had talked about this
the Tom show with Tom Arnold ranked the
132 out of 133 show worst TV show in
history it looked like hell and but I
worked with Ed McMahon and Tom Arnold
and I had a blast and brought me to LA
and I was like the fifth lead and I
remember going I made it I [ __ ] made
it and after the first season I walk on
the street I go look at me
nobody knows any and then I thought I
made it and I'm like wait a minute
I think I got paid $2,500 in episode
after taxes I thought when you come out
to California get on a TV show you're
famous yeah but no I think I had the
same experience until you are recognized
in something that is successful so by
the populace
Los Angeles but that you know yes but
doesn't don't you feel like now it's
like even if something's not successful
or whatever yeah it hurts a little bit
or whatever but you can't gauge success
through not being faced your priorities
change that's you know talking about the
20 year old you I mean that's a whole
other person when I Firefly was my first
TV job I had done like one independent
movie before that and I came out to LA
and I remember shooting and being like
people know who I am like no nobody
[ __ ] gives a [ __ ] and especially that
show which like didn't really make an
impact until it was cancelled and then
you know people sort of watch you get to
the fact you know those conventions that
make me well but now I mean it's crazy
how many people come up to me and
they're like you're in firefight kidding
me that was 20 years ago something well
smaller those 10 years ago can I left or
something it is I'm very we're very
lucky I know and it's beyond luck but
I'm just thinking it's amazing like I've
talked about this before she could fast
forward three seconds but Dax Shepard
says you know when he did chips in the
movie didn't do well he directed it and
it was the lead he said you know if I
would have went back and asked that
little boy a 12 year boy saying hey
you're gonna direct a big studio movie
and you're gonna be the star right do
you think he would have cared about how
much money it made out or how much all
you'd be like wow I get to do that
that's awesome because that's the inner
child and you and the kid that's what
should keep you going yeah it shouldn't
matter if this is a succession success
shouldn't dictate it should you know
make or break whether you are happy
about something like oh my god I'm I'm
not happy because this failed my success
doesn't dictate your happiness that's
thank you that's exactly I want to say
all right now we're we've come to a new
thing on the show yeah this is brand-new
uh-huh okay this is called shit-talking
okay with Rosenbaum okay my patreon fans
right they're part of patreon they
subscribe to podcast they get extra
footage and stuff
it's
they have some questions so I have ty
pick 10 questions for you ok ok it's
quickly answered you have to go on
forever
Danny favorite memory working in back in
the day probably being in the trailer we
were waiting around for something ended
up not being needed on set and Kim Kim
waltrip producer um she was like what
can I do for you guys I'm so sorry
there's a big delay we're like vodka and
a pizza and she was like okay she's like
don't tell Michael and we got we had a
bottle of vodka you were drunk I
remember and I didn't know what happened
why you were got a pizza we had the best
[ __ ] time in that shitty tiny trailer
with like five girls just drinking vodka
and [ __ ] talking and then we went to say
and we were very professional we got the
job done I think you did Matthew J who
made her break character more Ryan
Reynolds Deadpool Nathan Fillion Firefly
or Michael Rosenbaum and back in the day
no don't answer that
it's not me we're taking me out Ryan
Reynolds and Deadpool or Nathan Fillion
a fire but who'd make it a crack-up
those guys were very similar I'm gonna
say Ryan because he is so [ __ ] quick
on the jokes he's so quick it's
terrifying Leah s what's your favorite
memory or story from working on Stargate
I don't have a good memory of that one
would you not like it no it was totally
fine everybody was super nice but I had
to wear contacts and he [ __ ] up my
eyes and I was really pissed I like that
that's your worst memory instead of
favorite Lee or Leah yes that she gave
you the worst memory yeah the context
yeah the contacts sorry the drives
really hurt yeah I know really really
hurt Andria W if you had it your way in
the Firefly universe didn't Nara and
Malcolm finally get together would that
have been a complete train wreck
they couldn't those who would never
survive together I mean that's the
beauty of the relationship it's like
moonlighting you know you don't want
them together but they'd kill each other
together and then they would try again
and then they would kill each other
again and then they would try it you
know it would be like that but that's
you know the yumminess and that
relationship is that they will never
fully be together
Angie hi Angie what would be your dream
role
character to play and why oh that's so
hard there are so many I say this a lot
as a joke but I think I really mean it
nowadays um I want to be James Bond
there's nothing wrong with it how about
Jane bond or James Bond yeah [ __ ] me
why can't you be James Bond right there
are girls named James dude I can see
that because you know I used to want to
be a Bond girl but now I just want to be
happy
be James Bond Gerry w-who in the
filmmaking world inspires you and why
first person that came to mind because
we're talking about bond see view all
the bridge I'm obsessed with her
obsessed really I want to do anything
that she's associated with do you see
killing Eve no it's amazing flea bag is
incredible I saw her do it live in a
theatre it was so great oh my god Dionne
kay what was haven't seen flea bag no
dude you need to see flea bag really uh
yeah okay you could crush it on the
night yeah we're good yeah they're like
20 what's not a movie
no Amazon all right Dionne K what what
was it that sold you and Michael pitched
you the part and back in the day
honestly it was Michael like meeting you
hanging out with you I read the script
and it was cute and it was fun and funny
but alone it wouldn't have been enough
and like meeting you solidified it we
had met years before I don't know do you
remember that I was on set for a naughty
boys I thought you were with another guy
you were dating him yeah one of the guys
on there and you were yeah an [ __ ]
ish 20 year-old or whatever that story
where chance thank you
but it was when I remarry and we like
hung out and talked and so were you
surprised that you're like wow I'm doing
this no I liked it and I wanted to meet
you because that relationship is really
important and you have to really trust
there's no way I could have done that
movie without us trusting each other and
without me feeling like you had my back
I trusted you and you trusted me yeah
that was yeah and I needed to meet you
and and yeah and you were trying you're
attracted to me clearly Nico Nico says
what charities or organizations do you
like to support IRC the end
International Rescue Committee I like
that say this has been [ __ ] talking with
Michael Rosenbaum
I'm Morena Baccarin this has been [ __ ]
talking with Michael Rosenbaum I'm Reina
Baccarin alright so what's going on now
what woody what are you doing now he's
got all this stuff you had a family
you're always working I know you got
Greenland and post-production you got
another movie in post-production you're
jealous
three movies in post per day if three
movies in post-production I just worked
on so Greenland was awesome action movie
dirt but leur nicest man I've ever met
like sweet a sexy in person yeah yeah
yeah but I'd like a big teddy bear like
the sweetest guy ever could you get him
on the podcast yeah he would do it right
for you know for me why is it different
when you have fun yeah I like I'll tell
him I'm always like he's great he's a
really cool guy he lives here yeah
Waldo which is a film noir comedy with
Charlie Hunnam and Mel Gibson what was
it like working with Mel q I didn't get
to work with him but he's perfect for
this part actually he's like an
alcoholic angry actor who kills his wife
well good on him for actually doing that
which and this is like it's based on a
book and I [ __ ] loved working on this
so much anyway that was really fun to
work on it was stylized you know film
noir kind of speak but very funny do you
feel like you have to change your the
way you speak when you're doing more you
don't do this whole kind of thing do you
what you're doing with that no right but
the cadence was really important and the
it was very wordy the jokes were very
wordy so you have to kind of like know
where you're going right it's tough what
else what's the other project the other
project was called the good house with
Sigourney Weaver who I have a big-time
crush on now you work mr. Weaver I did
for how long
a few weeks like scenes with her we had
like a dozen scenes together
well she's great in were you nervous but
yes so my first day of work was her 70th
birthday
and she is so beautiful and so smart
and so powerful oh yeah and just such a
kind person any emotional scenes yeah
did you cry in front of her um no I I
was like a post cry scene where like I'm
upset and then I got across no not in
front of me did she say ever marina this
is really great job good scene yeah she
did she did I didn't went to heaven like
I died and went to heaven
like she talked to her okay keep in
touch yeah like you could text right now
sure you could text Sigourney we ever
just say hey yeah he want to do it yeah
you know what there was a story where my
friend was out with Jack Nicholson's
publicist and he took her phone they
were playing around he goes she has it
was you have Jack Nicholson he's like
yeah he's a client but like I'm not his
point person or whatever so he doesn't
know my you know no no no he starts
dialing it and she's no and he goes
hello he goes
Jack yeah I mean it's cool like when you
look for you sometimes I'm like can I
beat someone goes dude is that Jason
Patric and your phone I'm like he goes D
Jason and Mike yeah Lost Boys [ __ ]
yeah he's a friend we go hiking every
week he's a great guy I don't look you
don't mean but yeah he's right here
he sees my Lost Boys poster I told him I
actually thought it was a moment it
definitely was one of those moments
where I was like okay I I think I've
accomplished something here you know I
mean like she's an idol for sure you
know for she was like one of the major
badasses I mean and I I was I heard that
she really fought for me for this part
and like I really truly like that that
got me you know what I mean I was do you
feel weird like if you text her have you
text her since the movie yeah well we've
emailed each other back and forth well
what are the emails consist of like
something well she very sweetly and
again like so kind did not have to do
this
emailed me just after they wrapped
saying you know we just finished the
movie miss you you did a fantastic
I had given her a bottle of champagne
for her birthday after I realized that
she wasn't drinking the whole time she
was shooting the movie because the
movies about an alcoholic and it's very
a very emotional piece it's based on a
book and anyway she was like you know
what but I was so glad to have your your
bottle of champagne it came in handy
when we wrapped in the middle of the
night and couldn't get alcohol anyway
anyway we popped your bottle of
champagne thank you and thanks for for
the you know the great job you did on
the film and I wouldn't have to do that
and it's just a she's a very kind person
and very very genuine which was really
nice to see with somebody it's such a
huge could you ever ever think of maybe
quoting a line from a lien no but I
asked her a lot about I was like please
tell me but can I just ask you a million
and one questions you know and she was
very kind and answering and also just
some of you know I know some really
random movies that she was in like death
and the maiden which is based on a play
yeah I turned Ben Kingsley how about the
where she played a Jane Goodall yeah of
course gorillas in the mist
yeah and interesting to hear her talk
about some of her frustrations in the
industry and like all that [ __ ] and it
was just like I learned so much from her
that's so cool it was really incredible
and also a great project by the way like
I'm very proud of that what's called
yeah the good house the good house so
like you get all this stuff you've got
two kids you got a six year old and a
three year old
you got Ben your husband he's on
Broadway now yes I've got my 19-yard
aughh got a 19 year old dog good on you
I'm just talking about my little doggie
Irv and he's going on 12 and he's you
know he's getting old he's losing almost
his hearings gone people like why are
you yelling at you're talking like I'm
yelling because he can't hear now Rudy
hits every chair in the house every day
because he's blind and the kids are you
know they make a mess and they like
after breakfast or whatever the dining
room tables and chairs will be
everywhere and he just like if
everything is not in its place he runs
in just get hurt no not seriously hurt
it's just really sad this has been a
real treat what's your Instagram and
Twitter and your phone number for the
fans my phone number my phone number is
what you
griffons my name at Morena Baccarin at
Morena Baccarin have we left if anything
else is anything you want to talk about
mean there's a million things we could
talk about life anything but you'll come
back yes you said you're gonna come back
and do the video yes right yes I mean
this is I've been waiting I've been
wanting to do this I'm so glad you did
we're able to have a short dinner yeah
and talk about life yeah I'm extremely
proud of you I'm so glad you're mean you
seemed happy and content and I know your
periods rough talked about that ad
nauseam but you know look you you know
yourself
yeah you know when you drink on New
Year's Eve the next two days you're
gonna feel like [ __ ] yeah and when you
mix it you're gonna feel a little bit
worse right so give yourself a break say
hey I'm not feeling great and I'll
bounce back but I think it's really
important to honor yourself and that's a
hard thing to do to say you know what
I'm gonna stop drinking or I'm gonna do
whatever the thing is that I need to do
to get myself feeling better yeah you
know this has been great Ryan Jeff fun
yeah a great time just take some good
notes over that date cuz you don't me to
take notes so I took yeah well we could
talk about them later all right
Miranda back and thank you for allowing
me to be inside of you it's been a joy a
pleasure I love you I will always love
you I think you're one of the best out
there and I'll be calling you about
you're our Butler and potentially
scoring leader so thank you anything
let me tell you - I mean I love you
thanks for listening guys Morena
Baccarin come on
she's just so fun to be around right boy
just like I want to just hang with her
all night yeah I did actually they did I
left and you guys were still hanging
yeah we had dinner we facetimed her
husband there's nothing like lonely
single guy hanging out with a beautiful
Brazilian bombshell facetiming her
beautiful husband Ben who I love it was
cool it was it was neat and you can see
how much they love each other and I like
this interview because I've been trying
to get on the show forever and she when
you're married and you live in New York
and you're constantly working you know
the last thing I just say we come on my
podcast when you come out to California
and I was like but she was cool she
founds like hey I'm coming out do you
want to do this podcast thing like yes
let's do it so she came over we got food
and it was a nice time I wanted to talk
about the fans of the show
and people who listen and how much it
means to a lot of people out there that
are listening and if you're listening it
obviously means something to you so I
will say that some of these people who
write these emails I read them and this
is from Greenville South Carolina Billy
says I love the podcast it has something
for everyone it's fun hearing everyone's
stories including yours I'm glad that
you do this podcast it's therapy for you
it's very inspiring to know there are
people out there who generally want to
do good you might just be one of my
favorite people in the world laugh out
loud for real though you're doing an
amazing job amazing things and I hope
you get to a point where the podcast and
touring with the band is all you need to
do
keep kicking ass and saving the world
out there live love and be happy dude
well I thank you for that you know it's
hard for us to always say thank you
here's another letter that I just really
think is cool it's from Mary Ellen and
Mary Ellen says that she was a special
education teacher for several years and
has a special place in her heart for
kiddos with a DD and ADHD mm-hmm rings a
bell and listening to the interview with
Laura Vandervoort I'm feeling energized
and inspired to go back to school after
a break and really help my fifth graders
to become the shining stars I believe
each child can be this has been a hard
holiday season and I've been wasting a
lot of time you reminded me I needed
structure or I get lost in the dark
depression and loneliness I am planning
on going to Denver to see you and Tom in
July I've never been to an event like
that before my son who lives with me and
who introduced me to Smallville last
January when I was going through chemo
thinks I'm crazy but I really like the
message on the t-shirt that you posted
on the patreon site I have to write my
own story and it's not over yet thank
you so much much love and God bless miss
Mary Ellen
elementary school teacher I mean when
you hear that stuff you're like god I
did something awesome like I did
something that affected someone else man
it's that's it's it's cool like kids
need attention and when you have a TD no
one knows what to do about it you still
need care you still need love you're
gonna you're gonna be effed up I'll tell
you that now a shout-out to my patrons
Thank You patrons patrons for joining
this page
carry on it's amazing and thank you for
the support I hope you're enjoying it
good stuff to come here's some shoutouts
to Li s berry ie Deon K come on down
Lauren gee whiz Jill yeah Robert B ah
Jason www
Angelina G Lee Kevin R Trisha Nancy D
Bobby beatnik o P Yukiko Jerry W Taylor
B emily sarah v MH & board x good old
vortex Thank You patrons for making life
better making the the podcast better and
we're growing man we're getting the
video out soon we have to set it up and
then we're gonna start interviewing
people I hope the guests like it because
they're getting they're getting filmed
Ryan I you know some people go well what
if they don't open up as much then we'll
get rid of it we're just gotta so we got
to give it a chance you got it you got a
all the kids are doing it and I think
it's gonna be me I might have to dress a
little nicer but maybe in the cuts you
know I could look a little you know
maybe the shots can all be on the guests
you could have this be a uniform you
know this could just be your sweats and
a t-shirt yeah
never slowed me down a little hat you
know when I dress nicely on the internet
you know when I put like oh look this is
for my photo should be like rose mom you
look so good you look so nice and I
could tell they're saying stop dressing
like a [ __ ] slob dude I know that's
what they're saying and they're right
but I just I'm colorblind and it takes a
lot every day to go am i matching I
don't want to deal with this more
sweatpants see wear sweatpants because
you're colorblind
I need a woman who'll just accept
sweatpants whether we go out to a fancy
restaurant or not hey I want to remind
you guys at the inside of you store it's
still around and we still sell a lot of
stuff I don't promote it a lot but still
got great hats and great freakin mugs I
love the most we got shirts so go to the
inside of you store you'll even see left
on Laurel the band that I'm in you know
you'll you'll be able to see all our
merchants we got crazy fun merch so if
you feel so compelled I think that's
about it thank you so much we got great
stuff coming you great next week's guest
is gonna blow your freaking minds I know
it
let's end this with a little bit of a
a song from the left on Laura album I
don't know let's go with the ten
[Music]
here's on my show
I still can't take
[Music]
you told me time and
that you would just
[Music]
you know Stan
haha
guess among fans
least an ass
[Music]
you